she recently got a dog named after
japanese fermented soy beans natto uh
can we see oh you're not on screen yet
may watch you see the dog once you get
on screen so everyone please welcome
vivian
hi everyone my name is vivian i'm
currently uh the senior data scientist
at the city of la the mayor's office
um so today i want to start by playing a
game with you all
and i know it's a little cheesy but i
want to tell you a story and as i go
along the story i want you to i will
prompt and ask you to share um how how
you feel by adding an emoji to the to
the chat um on hop in and
we'll go along this journey so um i will
prompt you as we go it's a little cheesy
feel free to play along or just sit and
listen to this story
so the main character of our story is
the firstborn in the r family their name
is
one
okay
and so one day one is
one
one is walking along and they encounter
the firstborn of the python family name
zero
and so they say hey we're both
firstborns let's be friends
so then walking along they want to go
get ice cream now they're standing
inside of an ice cream shop looking at
the menu
they have one and zero standing next to
each other and so what if i told you
that
this number represents how much money
you have to spend in the ice cream shop
how does that make you feel
go ahead and add an emoji into the chat
of how if you had ten dollars to spend
on the icing shop how would that make
you feel
am i seeing these emojis
okay no one wants to play my game
um
jared is happy jerry loves ice cream i
know that i drew ice cream cone on his
wedding invitation okay so
oh there's a delay okay
that's okay it's coming through so we'll
keep going on this journey so next you
know they're walking along they come
across this bank and zero runs into
their extended family
um and they are so excited because they
haven't seen each other in a while and
they line up to see how tall they are
okay
so
now
this number represents how much money
you just won
um from one of those like scratcher
lottery games
um
so this is 10 000 free money that you
just have in your bank account now how
does that make you feel share some
emojis
i see smiley faces i see celebration
free money
sounds fun right
okay and so over the years some of
xero's family members have children and
now they're walking and they come
in this neighborhood and they see your
dream home
so they're standing outside lined up
looking at your dream home and this
represents how much money it costs to
buy your dream home one million dollars
how does that make you feel
cheers dollar signs
um
okay
and so let's say one day um one wants to
go on a vacation and so they say i'll
have my sibley come in and help out and
watch the kids right and so
one leaves and two comes over so now
this home is two million dollars how
does that make you feel
shock
okay i think you're getting the hang of
this so let's keep going so what if
instead of 2 million this home was now 3
million
continue to share emojis
okay so three million
sorry i need to see some sweat four
million dollars
popcorn
okay
five million dollars oh i see some
really intense eye emojis
like 5 million dollars now this home
costs 5 million dollars how does that
make you feel mind blown
yeah so i see a lot of mix of emojis and
so um similarly i had a journey as well
throwing up emojis sad face yeah
um i went through a similar journey so
this is how i felt going through the the
home
analogy
when it was one million dollars i felt
sad because i thought you know i don't
think any time within my near future i
can have a one million dollar home
two million dollars seems even further
so i felt really really um despondent
right once i got to the 3 million point
you know it was completely beyond my
realm of possibility so instead of
trying to think of how can i own this
home i can just stand and aw and admire
how beautiful the home is
and then cause of 4 million i started
thinking what do people do in their
lives that they can afford
a 4 million home
and they got to 5 million and i just
entered into this existential dread
right like what am i doing with my life
how come i am not making that much money
to have a 5 million home
so that was my journey and i see kind of
similarly like the evolution of emojis
that you all shared in the chat
um now
speaking of existential dread you know
what if that 5 million instead of
represented how much your home costs i
represented the number of global cova
deaths that we've experienced
how does that make you feel
um sad right i'm imagining sad
i feel sad when i hear that number it
feels like a crushing
um number of people
um but how sad
are we right it's the kind of sadness
that stays with us when it's top of mind
and we see it but it's also the kind of
sadness that
kind of goes away when i move to the
next slide
and i notice this um you know in the u.s
when we hit reached our
100 thousand deaths due to covet in the
us and new york times
dedicated their front page to all those
who passed you know all the names um and
stories about each individual
and this was widely shared right a lot
of people gave you know um shared on
social media
um there were special dedications and
stuff like that when we reached um this
number
you know four months later we reached
200 000
and it felt like people barely bat an
eye you know there are no longer any
special kind of dedications or are um
a moment that was around reaching this
number
and i think that has something to do
with how numbers scale in our mind
you know how do we really distinguish
what a hundred thousand feels like
compared to um two million or five
million it's really
difficult to tangibly feel what those
numbers mean
and we kind of reach this threshold
where
you know in our brains we can't hold the
truth of that number um the difference
between like one two three four five
million um as data people i think we
understand the skill of it and we
really feel
the difference when we're working with
like numbers um or data that is in that
scale
um but when we're just seeing the number
on the screen it just looks like one
digit is changing
and then you know
the the impact of that number is kind of
lost
so most of the work that i do is trying
to get a sense of that impact and really
get a feel of what these numbers look
like
previously when i was at doctors without
borders my work was a lot around
storytelling you know creating
illustrations and animations around
the issues that we work on
and since i transitioned into
a data scientist my work looks more like
this you know i spent the past year and
a half
tracking covert trends in la city
and building reports and dashboards that
help inform
the mayor policy makers and the general
public around our current trends
and as i'm creating these tools i think
a lot about the game that we just played
how numbers um
for humans can both be we can both be
impacted and desensitized to numbers at
the same time
and going into the third year of our
pandemic i think about how do we keep
these numbers relevant
truthful
and maintain a level of urgency where it
can still command someone's attention
given the context of everything else
people are dealing with
so today i want to share
pull back a little bit and share what i
believe are the building blocks of
design
this is not a talk about color theory or
what charts to use
um it's
really going you know what i think back
to basics and
sharing how to
like think like a designer
um
so in the design world we spend the
majority of the time not just
understanding the problem but
understanding who is impacted by this
issue
and i know you you've heard it before
right
everyone says
you know define your audience and
usually what i hear people how people
answer this i hear you know for example
the mayor or the ceo or
you know millennials
who are about to be first-time parents
you know it kind of stops at that one
line
and i want to share today you know how
a few questions that i use to help
define my audience and how that
framework can be helpful and informing
the visuals that you create
so the questions that i explore are one
like who is your primary audience
how do you want them to feel and what
action
do you want them to take
so what i mean by primary audience is
really beyond like their job title right
um what do they care about
um what problem are they trying to solve
and
something that i think is really
important is what limitations are they
working with so everyone has some kind
of time limitation especially when
you're creating
things online you know you're always
going to be competing with people's
attention span
are there tech barriers that that are
limiting uh data literacy right um
everyone
regardless of if you're a data scientist
or not has like some level of discomfort
with with numbers and so um you know but
it's a as a designer it's up to you to
think about how do you um adjust for
that level of data literacy
is there bureaucracy you know so within
an organization maybe they really care
about the issue but they may not
themselves have influence to be able to
make decisions to change around that
and so if you identify that that is
something that is um impacting your
audience then that helps you go beyond
and think okay who do they have to
influence to help kind of
change policy or to be able to make
decisions
next i think a lot about feelings
obviously
you know um and i think about one like
what emotions are they walking into this
with
and just understanding that generally
people have a discomfort with numbers
you know how they may be feeling timid
or some kind of like imposter syndrome
walking into um something that is
looking at really dense numbers right
but when i think about if i have a
chance to interact with something that i
work on how how do i want them to feel
walking away from this after having
engaged with the report or the dashboard
and when i was doing um
work as an advocacy person you know that
emotion changed depending on what i was
working on
sometimes i really wanted people to feel
angry and take action with us
um sometimes i wanted them to feel sad
so that they can be empathetic and have
a conversation around this and
oftentimes just maybe relief too that
someone is working on this issue
if you
are kind of stuck and you don't know how
you want your audience member to feel
you know um this is a philosophy that
i've been kind of working on lately is
if you don't know
up for happy like choose happy right the
world is really really dark these days
and heavy and if someone has a chance to
interact with something that you create
you know why not give a moment a levity
and lightness and
i don't mean to that you know you should
do like rose tinted glasses and if a
report is really dense kind of like
change the numbers or you know change
the frame so it's all light and happy
and positive what i mean by this is
really um giving a sense of um
kind of grasp over the numbers so i
think a lot about how people are
uncomfortable with numbers
and so if i build a dashboard or a
report for them you know i want them to
feel like
confidence like oh i understand what
this means
i can then take away
these numbers and and trends and then be
able to
share that with someone else right i
want them to feel confident about the
numbers and not be so intimidated by it
so that's what i mean by happy
um the next is you know from there like
what action do you want them to take is
it a one-time action is it ongoing um
you know
that helps me think through okay do i
need to do like a one-off visual or
graph or
you know i'm a shiny queen and so i'm
always saying do you want to do a
dashboard for um for this issue
um
what can they control versus who do they
need to influence and what's a key
takeaway message
so these three questions are pretty um
pretty basic and easy to answer and i do
this often with my team as i set time
you know just even 10 to 15 minutes to
kind of brainstorm and sit together
and say if we're thinking about
launching this product you know who is
our audience and brainstorming with like
all levels of my team i open this up to
to everyone not just the data scientists
working on it
and because then you can go through each
kind of audience member and understand
like what are the key um
uh
key motivating points for for this
project and then be able to kind of get
different perspectives from everyone who
is working on this
um and so this is great to kind of start
and launch a project but then also it's
a good reference to come back to as you
are developing the product um because
you know in the creative process there
is going to be ups and downs and you
know things will con iterate and it
makes start to
you know change and evolve as you go and
using this as a reference to continue to
come back and think through is it still
aligning with the things that we
identified as important
from the beginning of this project right
and sometimes you know um it's going to
be hard to navigate that conversation to
think through um is it still aligning
how do we change and evolve it
without
shutting down ideas right so i want to
end on um
just sharing some language that i have
helped
found useful that helps me navigate
those kind of conversations where you
can still be creative and open and not
have it shut down the the process so
here just language that i have found
useful um in thinking of sometimes when
i see i see something and in my mind i'm
thinking like why why is this here right
but if you're on the receiving end of
the y i have often been on the receiving
end and it doesn't feel good um it feels
like you know um
there's no confidence in in the work or
the decisions that we're making and so i
have found it helpful to instead shift
and say can you help me understand how
this is being used
and if you look at these lines here you
know the questions that i am suggesting
is kind of more
you know how about if we tried this
would it make a difference if we shifted
you know here to this to here or change
the colors um
tell me what you think about this what's
working and the theme along all of this
language suggestion is all around
getting
uh helping people define like what is
working right and if it is working then
let's keep that but if that is not
coming across like at a first glance not
intuitively how can we
evolve it so that it
it does feel intuitive for everyone who
comes across it and that way you can
continue to keep the core of what works
and then have it iterate and evolve
without it shutting down um
kind of keeping the conversation going
so i hope this was helpful um feel free
to take what you think is useful
and evolve
for how this might be helpful and the
work that you do
thank you